The joe rogan experience.
I think there's a balance to doing things and it's highlighted by what you just
said,
what you've just said.
There's a balance and it's a lot of what we were talking about earlier about uh,
Joel Jamison versus Louie Simmons versus like someone who's like super technical
versus someone who's just a fucking mad dog and just wants you to just go out
and do it and don't be a pussy.
Your your mindset that allowed you to take that fight with no training and then
take another fight after that with no training and then take another fight out
to that would know t d just this mindset of fuck it,
let's just do this.
There's a balance between that and then you realizing,
okay,
I got to really learn how to do this.
If I'm going to really be a fighter,
I'm going to be really be a really defined myself and I'll really go out and
make a mark.
I got to learn what the fuck I'm doing.
Exactly this both things there.
That's that balance.
Like you need both things,
you know?
I mean it's,
it's,
you have to have a certain amount of fuck it in you,
you know,
you have to have a certain amount for a sport.
I mean,
is he called an MMA a sport?
It always seemed to me to be,
it's too,
it's too defining.
It's or two.
Uh,
it's,
it's too limited.
It's not fighting is more than a sport.
It's an expression of what you're capable of.
Absolutely.
It's,
you are who you are as a human.
And that's where a one distinction I've made over the years is the difference
between Marshall skills in martial arts.
Every,
everybody always calls everything and copies it into a martial art.
And when we go to the gym and we're training armbars do a hundred arm bars,
that's not art.
That's not your expression of your body in a combat scenario.
That's a,
that's a martial skill.
Now when we go in competition,
now we're expressing our R and I think this is an important distinction to be
made.
I think it's something that,
uh,
I get so tired of hearing,
you know,
I trained martial arts and you know,
I trained martial skills.
And then I express my art.
That's a very interesting way of putting it.
How many years after you initially started seriously training where you on the
ultimate fighter?
Uh,
four or five.
I remember when you were on the ultimate fighter and they stole your chew.
Somebody fuck with you.
Treat everybody remembers him.
Well,
I remembered that because I remember like there's some dudes that,
there's some guys that play tough guy.
There's some guys that put on a show and puff up their chest and say some shit
that they might not necessarily mean.
And then there's some guys that say some shit and you go,
oh this dude's fucking serious.
When they fucked with your kid or with your shoe.
I remember watching that and go,
this motherfucker serious.
I'm like,
Matt Brown is not a joker.
And then when you fought Matt Arroyo,
that was a another example of it.
I'm like there's skill wise Mike matter.
Roy was a very talented guy and still is good Jujitsu guy.
Good.
But there was something that was a battle of minds.
I agree.
Your mind,
I don't know if you knew that I fought him before that too.
Yeah,
I did.
Right.
But the first time I fought,
and this is why it was such a,
a no brainer to say,
to fight,
I fought him the first time on 24 hours notice.
So I wasn't even,
I wasn't training her and I was training a girl and she was going to Florida to
fight.
And when I got there,
we're driving to the weigh ins and the promoter,
I heard him talking on the phone and he goes,
and I heard him say,
you know,
oh,
we don't have an opponent for him.
Uh,
so I said,
hey,
you know,
what do you need opponent for?
And he's like,
wow,
this guy mad Arroyo one 70.
And I said,
dude,
I'll fight like how much we pay me and then I can have 400,
500 bucks.
I was like,
dude,
I pay my rent.
Fuck yeah,
I'll do it.
And um,
yeah,
so,
and I said,
you know,
I can't make weight because I got like one hour and uh,
he said it.
He said it's cool and fight him on 24 hours notice and beat him.
So he wanted redemption for that.
You know,
that fight was you,
one of the things about like watching you fight as someone who's seen a lot of
people fight,
there's,
there's moments in exchanges were after the exchange,
a gile tried to take a break or gow try to catch his breath or move pays that
bigotry break.
Yeah,
call it,
there's little breaks and then there's guys recognize those breaks and push in
and you're a guy who pushes in.
Absolutely.
When there's a break you're like,
oh no motherfucker,
there's no breaks here.
There's no breaks here.
And you just get on dudes.
And it makes things very intense.
Yeah.
That's the thing about all your fights.
They're very intense.
You know,
there's a,
there's a certain level of violence that you bring into the octagon that someone
has to be prepared for,
you know,
and there's some guys that are prepared for it and it makes for amazing fights,
like your fight with Robbie Lawler.
Holy Shit.
Was that a crazy fight?
You know?
And then there's guys who just,
they just can't keep the pace.
They just can't keep that then keeping you off of them.
Yeah.
And I think w um,
my goal as a martial artist,
as a fighter Marshall,
uh,
you know,
whatever you would call a combat guy,
I had to get my skills up to the point where your mind where it matches the
mind.
Yeah.
And crazy.
I mean,
a lot of guys struggle the other way and I think one of the things that I talk
about a lot that you see,
I don't think that I was necessarily born this way.
This is where I think a lot of people get confused.
I mean,
I was certainly born with an inclination towards fighting.
I wouldn't be where I'm at without that.
But,
you know,
uh,
I work a lot on my mind.
I do a lot of stuff.
I've always been obsessed with martial arts and combat as a whole.
And I hear other people say they're obsessed.
Like,
Connor,
you made it really famous when he started saying it.
Right.
I think my obsession goes far,
far beyond what anybody's even even close to.
I don't think they're there.
Uh,
definition of obsession,
even,
uh,
is comparable to mine at all.
I mean,
I'm,
I'm far more obsessed.
I,
I've read probably I got a library of sports psychology,
books of,
of strength conditioning,
books of a martial arts,
books,
all this stuff.
Um,
I mean it's literally on my mind 20 hours a day,
but one of the things I really focus on is the,
the sports psychology part.
And I think that is why it's expressed that way in the fight.
Um,
and you hear a lot of people,
they'll say,
yeah,
how often have you heard like men,
you know,
my mind is already strong.
Like,
I ain't scared when I walked in.
There are stupid shit like that.
And I always say,
you know,
do you think Michael Jordan stopped packs and layups?
Do you think Jordan Burroughs stopped practicing double legs?
Do you think that on a shorts and niggers stopped doing bicep curls?
It because it's good doesn't mean that you stop.
Yeah.
It can be improved upon and you don't stop.
So,
and I think the mind is one of those things that can always be better.
Like we're not tapping into,
I mean,
what are we talking is like 10% of our brains and that's all blessed.
Yeah.
That's bullshit.
You know,
they used to think that.
They used to think that they used to it.
That's something they say.
But the reality is,
uh,
your brain has a bunch of different quadrants for all sorts of different
functions.
So when you know you're utilizing a certain portion of your brain,
that's the portion of your brain that's responsible for those actions.
Okay.
Yeah.
There's not either way.
Our minds are certainly far more unlimited and far more potential than we're
tapping into.
I think your mind is a lot like your body and it performs and it does what you
ask of it.
And if you just are lazy pitch,
it doesn't do anything but sit around and watch TV and you don't ever challenge
your mind.
I think your mind is weak and it atrophies.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
When you say that you,
you have all these books and you say that you work on your mind,
like do you have a daily practice that you do?
Do you meditate,
you can meditate?
Um,
you know,
daily is sort of a,
uh,
I hate saying I do it daily cause you know,
I skipped days and,
and I mean I have three kids,
which,
you know,
how that goes and yeah,
it's a very,
um,
but at the same time I try to use everything as an opportunity to practice on my
mind too.
Right.
Um,
um,
how you do anything is how you do everything.
Right?
Right.
Um,
and so I think,
you know,
we can use opportunities all the time and uh,
but yes,
I do meditate,
I do tons of visualization.
I have a,
um,
my strength conditioning coach I work with now,
he's a,
he's also got degree in sports psychology.
So we integrated a lot of that in the training itself.
Uh,
for instance,
like doing,
we do these 200 yard sprints on the forest treadmill,
or they're just miserable.
That,
I mean,
by the time you're done,
you just don't have anything left.
It's a complete drain.
And then as soon as you're done,
like if stand at attention,
right,
I have to in,
you know,
like a military attention,
straight up and down and not let the,
uh,
the,
the concept of your body's shutting down affect your ability to maintain a
posture.
Right?
And that's just a mental thing,
you know,
100% right is solely mental.
Um,
the,
that's just one example.
We do a million things like that.
Um,
but yeah,
I do,
I do tons and tons of visualization,
which is,
uh,
consistent,
marker of high performers are consistent thing that high performers do.
I think this is a well known.
Um,
I have a,
a mental coach specifically that kind of holds me accountable for a lot of the
things,
you know,
me and him,
we talk a lot back and forth about the different,
uh,
the different,
um,
ways to create habits.
I think that's probably the number one thing is creating habits.
Right?
Um,
you know,
but you know,
he holds me accountable for everything and not take,
that's probably the biggest key is just being held accountable for every action
that you do.
Have you ever used a sensory deprivation tank?
Absolutely.
My,
uh,
my strength coach has one.
Beautiful,
yeah,
I love it.
And I go in about 45 to an hour to work on shit in there.
Do you think about techniques?
Um,
you know,
I don't really,
uh,
I used that as a time,
so I've,
I tried to practice this form of meditation that I,
you know,
I can't remember the name of it,
this dude,
um,
Kish tomorrow.
You ever heard of him?
Krishnamacharya,
I don't know why he's not coming to my head right now,
but he was one of Bruce Lee's guys.
He's an Indian metta meditation guy and everything.
And um,
his form of meditation was to completely clear your mind,
which is,
I guess I is actually impossible,
right?
Like there's no way to just have no thought at all,
but that's sort of what I try to strive for is go literally no mind at all.
What I do is think about only my breath.
That's it.
I concentrate on my breathing in and when I do that and there's a bunch of other
shit that gets in there,
but eventually I can kind of overpower it and just think only about breathing in
and out.
So that's what I do to get to that state [inaudible] right?
To get to a state where I can release everything.
But at that point,
once out,
mom relaxed,
then I go for the,
uh,
the no mine,
which again is a,
it's impossible.
But,
um,
my personal system of visualization or relaxation is I see the thoughts as
clouds and the,
my mind is a sky or space.
So,
you know,
my mind becomes this gigantic,
uh,
entity and the thoughts are just clouds that pass by.
But again,
when I start thinking about things like that,
now you're not in the,
no mine.
If you start thinking about your breath,
you're not in the know mine.
Right?
And I want to get as close to it as possible because in a fight,
in a combat situation,
I want no mind.
Right?
That's the,
as the way that Musashi talks about,
right?
Yeah.
And as customer Sasha right there.
Oh,
fuck.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
This was a rings play on massage.
Yeah.